Jill what made you want to write it's
funny in the dedication to my book I
dedicate it to my father who loved
instilled my love of movies in me
and to my mother who always knew I was a
writer from my earliest you know
childhood I can remember I want I told
everyone I wanted to be a writer I loved
creating stories I loved you know
writing little scripts that you know we
would do on 8-millimeter I've just I've
always kind of had that in me
a love of words it's just a perfect way
of expressing yourself and you know when
you find something that feels right it's
just the most perfect way to express
yourself in the world you know were you
good at Scrabble
you know I actually probably am NOT
great I tend to be a sore loser
I'll admit to you so I only I'm only
good at things that I really excel at I
remember we had a chess tournament in
school when we were like we were just
taught it in fourth grade or something
and I thought wow I'm really smart and I
played chess with my father and I got
beat in the first round and you know it
I've never played chess sense I'm kind
of a sore loser
so well I have a love of words I think I
also have a love of things like Google
in order to find the right word and and
all the modern conveniences to help us
cheat to find those things I'm a little
less motivated when it's just a game
board in front of me we'll stick with
what you know yeah can you think back to
one of your first scripts and when you
look at now where you are and having
critique people's work and rewritten it
and all the things that you've done in
your career what was wrong with your
first script I had the chronic problem
that ends the whole reason I created my
method the whole thing that is behind
the nutshell technique I wrote so
everybody thinks they've got a great
idea right for a movie they don't
would everyone what you might have is
the great idea for one you don't have a
story though you have what I would call
a situation and and it and I would
identify that as in my work as a script
consultant ninety-nine percent of the
time that's what writers are writing
they're failing to write a story instead
they're creating a situation life is the
situation right life is this happens
then this happens then this happens then
this happens that's not a story story is
this happens which leads to that
happening which makes it ironic when
this other thing happens there's this
connection between the parts and that's
the problem I'm seeing in 99% of writers
that they are creating a situation not a
story and that was exactly my problem I
had a great I thought a great idea who
this would make a great movie and I
couldn't understand why I was feeling so
blocked and having a hard time writing
it I thought it was me I thought it was
I must not be a good enough writer or I
must not be talented enough no the
problem well that might be true too but
the other problem was I didn't have
technique basically and technique to
understand the difference between what a
situation is and what a story is so if
you just have a situation you're going
to be laboring to get from moment to
moment to moment and and there's not
going to be a natural connection and an
actual progression and so it's gonna
feel stilted it's gonna feel unnatural
it's gonna feel like bad writing but
with the technique that's that's the
secret to making something feel like an
organic story that has has resonance and
has power it's not just reading
somebody's diary of unconnected events
these different events that happen to
somebody there's there's a glue that is
existing behind them that makes them the
coherent so I absolutely suffered from
the exact same problem that I've been
addressing that's the whole reason I
created my method to remember where you
were or what was going on when you sort
of
that aha moment about that in terms of
like was something did you bored you
watch him something and I was getting
kind of a similar note to the one I
described that people were saying things
like they were using different words but
they were saying essentially this isn't
really a story it's a situation the only
thing was no one could explain to me the
difference and so I had a sense of what
the difference was I had good training I
had studied at Columbia University I'd
also studied with some private
screenwriting programs in New York City
and I learned a lot of good things in
these different programs but no one was
bringing it all together and I could
sense in this note I knew there was
truth in what I was hearing even though
no one could explain to me how to
transform it I got what they were saying
and I had a sense that they're sort of
if I make a huge generalization to
approaches out there one is a linear
approach a strictly three-act structure
you know beat method kind of approach to
screenwriting and the other is a more
character based character arc approach
the problem I was having and the problem
that 99% of writers are having I could
tell belonged somewhere in the
intersection between these methods but
these methods do not exist if a story is
functioning properly
these are not separate things character
arc in three acts story structure there
are actually very specific points where
they need to intersect and if you fail
to hit those intersections you're going
to end up with a situation but not a
story and so with this note I was
getting I started analyzing movies I
started deconstructing movies and you
know do you construct hundreds of them
just kind of obsessively taking notes
and trying to find these moments and it
took a little while and right off the
bat I can identify
I essentially identify eight elements
that are required to tell the story and
my method and that and these are
interconnected elements these are not
beats these are not moments in time
these are elements of the story and I'd
say right off the bat I knew what five
of them were but it took a little while
of analyzing movies and then it did
happen there was kind of this
breakthrough moment on the last like
last movie that I deconstructed in this
period where I was like boom to eighth
method I was like oh my god this
actually works I can't believe it
what movie was you know I I don't know
that I can identify the movie I have
notebooks full of them at that time but
it was kind of like holy cow this
actually works once at once that last
one dropped and then I I could use those
eight things and apply it up against
every movie from then on it was like oh
my god they're there they're there I
can't believe it it's there in every
single movie when you go into several
movies in your book yeah I do
mm-hmm right from Chinatown to silver
linings playbook just you run the gamut
yeah I made a point of doing that so the
book and I'll show you back yeah
beautiful cover much yeah thank you so
it's a nice lovely large format book and
I'd recommend people get the paperback
not the Kindle for that reason okay
because it's a just a beautifully
designed large format book and one of
the big features of the book is the last
section
I have in it 30 different Oh movies
that's great so it's all my one nutshell
form you want to form 30 different
movies and so the books are designed for
you to flip back and forth when you're
reading and I I mentioned a movie so
that you can look and see how it fits in
the in the Alpha by alphabetical listing
of movies in the back you can see how
that element fits into the whole picture
so yeah I have everything you know in
the back from Casablanca to Pulp Fiction
to August Osage County right movies that
are different time periods different
genres movies you probably think had
almost nothing in common
structure-wise other than maybe three
acts maybe I can identify these eight
elements and all of these different
so I just wanted to illustrate that this
is not a formulaic you know it's not a
formula right we're talking about very
very different movies that are not
following one template no one would say
the template to pulp fiction in
Casablanca or anything alike right but
underlying it they have at the very
basis they have the same structural
elements that we're looking at and that
are required for making them the great
movies that they are they're the same
eight things going on sorry to interrupt
but I you can email is that right if
someone would like a graph yes so my
next shelf form so this is the central
tenets of my method is my nutshell
technique form basically I drew up these
eight elements that are required to tell
a story on and put it on a one-page form
from a clients and my students and
rather glibly wrote on the first one
screenplay is in a nutshell and that's
how the name was born it's great um yeah
and so this form I can use the it's a
visual method so we can look we can see
right on the piece of paper what's
working and not working not working and
yes anyone can download it my website
Jill Chamberlin calm you can download
free versions of the these worksheets
for your own use great so you can take
that Y at a nutshell technique and start
playing around with it start using it
for your own stories
so this away and what's important I want
to emphasize it's not just it's
different than the B cheat methods these
are not beats in time there are four of
these are moments in time the rest of
them are and what's really different is
the interconnection between the parts I
don't know any other method in the three
thousand books on screenwriting they're
on Amazon none of the other ones that
I'm aware of explains the connection
between the parts most of the books
you're going to find on Amazon that deal
with structure they do what I call a
beat sheet method where they tell you
you're supposed to hit these pre
prescribed fifteen or twenty two or
however many beats that happen in a
typical Hollywood movie I'm throwing all
that out
these are not moments in time other than
a first seen al a seen you know
identifying things like that these are
other structural elements to the story
other than moments in time what's
important is the connection between the
parts the glue that's going to hold them
together
I'm wondering what a movie looks like
when it's just a bunch of situations
strung together yeah so how does that
look let's suppose a screenwriters done
that they haven't fixed it now the films
out there what does that look like
it feels so it feels episodic that's
another way to put it where it's kind of
one moment after a moment where each
it's almost like we're seeing separate
short films struck strung together
instead of one coherent story by the way
not every movie tells a story I'm
talking about movies that tell a story
actually some of the films Richard
Linklater famously you know he and he
has said this quite a bit that the
movies like slacker and boyhood are
great movies they're not telling a story
though right in in right it's not one
coherent story it's looking at a slice
of life it's looking at different
following a character there might be
some things the matically pulling it
pulling them in common but it's not a
story
social slacker yeah yeah so it's it's
it's not a not every movie tells the
story I have to say though it's
extremely rare to find a movie in
theatres that doesn't tell a story
that's you know it's pretty unusual so
that you know that the Richard Linklater
is the exception of to the rule where we
see something that's successful that we
can be moved by that actually isn't
telling a story the vast majority of the
time movies need to tell a story for us
to feel satisfied we're gonna get
restless it's gonna feel episodic we're
gonna get lost on tangents why are we
following this character what did that
moment have to do with that moment
they're going to be things that happen
that where you're setting plants but
you're not paying off so and it's a
chronic problem that I see in
screenwriters that they are failing to
tell a story you touch on something
regarding the nine
percent and you say many writers can
format a script but most writers can't
do and that is yeah so in my experience
as a script consultant 99% of writers
fail to tell a story that what the 99%
do instead is I would describe as
present a situation so they pay me good
money as a script consultant to come in
and read their script it may be
perfectly formatted in industry standard
it may have some interesting characters
here and there and have some great
dialogue may have some interesting plot
points but invariably I was discovering
99% of the time they were failing to
tell a story instead they were
presenting a situation so you know one
way that I can describe it a situation
is it's like life where in life this
happens then this happens then this
happens and that's not a story
right that's episodic a story there's a
connection where between the parts this
happens which leads to that happening
which makes it ironic when this other
thing happens there's a connection
between the parts another way I can put
it is if I can take your protagonist out
of your script and pull it a completely
different one in and maybe with a couple
of tweaks it works just as well you have
a situation my friend not a story
interesting I shouldn't be able to do
that if you're telling the story if I
were to take your protagonist out it
would no longer work a story is unique
to your protagonist there's something
there's a unique journey a reason why
you the master of the universe here has
put this character on this path there's
something in that character that you've
chosen to do this particular plot in
order to bring out something in them and
so if I can put just another character
in it works just as well that's not a
situation that's not testing anything
specific to the character it's just an
arbitrary situation that you put a
character you put someone into and
that's what most people do I mean that's
the way a lot of a star
it's not you know I don't mean to it
doesn't mean that it's not a fixable
situation and that's why my method is
why I have these on forms that we can
see visually right there and then oh
yeah this is this piece is working but
you can see this piece doesn't work we
can isolate these elements and we can
fix them looking at this one-page form
and it's way easier to do it on this
one-page form then if you've already
written a screenplay then that's gonna
be a bit more of a mess we could still
use the form but it's gonna be it's
gonna mean going back a little bit to
the drawing board in order to fix those
parts in order to make it into a
powerful story I wonder if we can
reverse engineer a current film that's
out and make it into a situation so I
know sometimes I use movies that are
dated so let me try to like a star is
born how could we reverse engineer it so
that if we broke it down and we changed
it to a situation so we could see like
dissect it let me give you a different
example sure my favorite it's my
favorite example okay it is the movie
Tootsie oh that's right love so great
every screenwriter
every filmmaker should know Tootsie
right if you haven't saw you we have to
go see it it's great movie to look
structurally this is what is exactly
what's happening
99% of writers are writing what I call
fat tootsie okay this is fat tootsie I'm
gonna take the same movie Tootsie we
have a protagonist Michael Dorsey
out-of-work actor right can't get an
acting job and he's desperate for an
acting job and so he's gonna audition
for the soap opera and I'm gonna make
two very small changes to the plot is
he's got auditioned for the soap opera
in disguise but what it is the part
isn't a female character the part is
gonna be a male character but the
character is an obese man in the
fictional soap opera world and so for
the town that the soap opera takes place
in so Michael Dorsey is desperate for an
acting job right so he's gonna go to his
makeup artist friend to have prosthesis
made and a costumer to make him a fat
suit and he's gonna go into the audition
pretending that he's actually an obese
man and he's gonna get the part
so we have exact same movie Michael
Dorsey out-of-work actor desperate for
an acting job gets a part on a soap
opera the only thing I'm going to change
is instead of the part being a female
character it's the part of a fat man
right
very similar movie almost works right we
tend to think it's funny seeing a man
dressed up as a woman in movies we also
could find it funny seeing this little
you know guy like Dustin Hoffman
pretending to be a big fat guy right
he's got to get in and out of his fat
suit
you know before anyone sees him it
almost works but ultimately that twit C
is a situation not a story you have any
idea what the difference might be I'm
trying to forgive me it's been a it's
been a little bit since I've seen it I'm
just remembering like when he is Tutsi
that you know there's like this sort of
where someone falls in love with him and
there's this like dilemma like how do
like you know how does he tell them he's
a man he can he's got to keep his cover
so what would be yeah and I could even
tweak it though when that was an issue
we're in in it he gets say um questions
female costar right I'll make another
tweak though for fat Tutsi okay he'll
tell his co-star that he's gay so fact
so she Fiat Julie the love interest
feels just as comfortable with him her
co-star who she perceives as this gay
fat man right she feels just as
comfortable with him as she felt with
the Dorothy character the female persona
so still almost works right we have the
exact same thing and then for the love
interest because he's he says he's gay
part of the real in the movie the tinted
see that his Julie's father gets a crush
on the Dorothy character Rob will make
will make Julie's father gay right so
that could work so it's still working
the same you stumped me yeah I'm gonna
get I some but this is the key to this
is key and let me tell you
99% of writers are writing fat Twitty
it's a clever sounding such
raishin but it's not a story the key the
big difference is one of the the biggest
structural this is one of the eight
elements but it's the most important
element is the flaw that there's
something in this journey that you've
chosen in the plot you've created that
you put this character in that's gonna
test a central flaw in them any idea
what Michael door sees flaw might be
well I guess he's struggling with his
career yeah he speak out but if lost
something we can blame them went for so
something look at them you look down
upon them so what would you say it's
what is a negative about him that we're
judging we can judge him about right in
the ballpark though it has to it's
related to his career all right lack of
confidence lack of skill maybe he's not
honey
I don't know going up arts he has a
different overinflated a view of himself
under-inflated I don't know well I think
most people point out the overinflated
view that he's very very arrogant right
that he is that's you know one of the
reasons he hasn't been getting acting
work is because he's so difficult to
work with the only thing is I would
argue after the movie Trixie do you
think this guy is gonna be any less
arrogant on his next acting job no
because he was able to pull it off right
and so now he has exactly yeah exactly
so that hasn't yes
that is one of his flaws arrogance it's
not the one that the movies testing the
one that the movies testing is his lack
of respect for women ah
okay right so we've seen the beginning
this early scene at this party he hits
on every single woman with the same
stupid line right even though I think
he'd probably call himself a feminist
he's actually a real jerk to women right
he's you know he's great friends with
the Teri Garr character and but the
moment they sleep together
he suddenly freaks out and shrieks
treats her terribly so deep down he is
this lack of respect for women that is
the perfect test of somebody who has a
lack of respect for women if you make
them have to pretend to be a woman
interesting right but in fat two-seat
that has nothing to do with his flaw
it's an arbitrary situation we put him
in
so unless we were to change the flock we
made the flaw you know somebody who had
a prejudice against people you know of
different weight or different appearance
something like that we could do we could
we could change the character so it was
testing someone but with the character
that's in the original Tootsie of this
man who was arrogant and doesn't respect
women putting them in a fat suit that
doesn't do anything to test that
character right so that's what 99% of
writers are doing it sounds clever right
sounds interesting to see somebody you
know he's trying to pretend seems to be
has some interesting themes about being
someone who trying to pretend to be
someone who you're not we've got some
funny comedy moments ideas in there it
has nothing to do with the character
right and he gets hit on and I remember
the one scene where they're like can you
guys back up the camera like how far can
we go so he's being judged for his looks
being hit on all these different things
I'll be seeing right right right he does
even in the movie in the in in Cocke you
know in that second act he still doesn't
realize it you know that he's been doing
these things all along and it's it's
there's a great moment where the sexist
director turns things around and says
something what about the fact that that
you know he's the sexist director has
been dating Julie and the his Michael's
Dorothy persona it's kind of suggests I
know what's going on and and the
director says yeah yeah you know yeah
sure I see other women but I wouldn't
want to tell her I wouldn't want to hurt
her right and Mike endorsees used that
exact same line talking about Teri Garr
right of course you know I don't want to
hurt her right so he doesn't even
realize he's doing these things sure so
this is the way this is the way we're
gonna get the character to finally face
something so another important concept
about this is that your characters not a
victim Michael Dorsey is not a victim of
the universe suddenly making him have to
be a woman and deal with that he
actually asked for this he wanted an
acting part he said he could handle this
he said I'll take you no I'll do
anything I'll do any acting job he
willingly went in there an audition for
this so this is another part of the 99%
they're making their character
a victim of circumstance they're having
arbitrary stuff happened to the
character it shouldn't be your character
should not be a victim even if your
character is a victim for them truly to
be a protagonist they then you have a
certain amount of agency involved they
need to be contributing to the problem
in some way if you don't give your
character a strong flaw you're just
making them a victim
the reason these bad things are
happening to them they're just faked
it's just bad luck in the world it
shouldn't be that that might be part of
it but it needs to be part of you know
why it's so difficult for Michael Dorsey
and Tootsie is the fact that he's sexist
if he were a sexist guy he wouldn't have
been having a difficult time in act 2 of
Tootsie so what we're doing is that
we're making sure that we're testing the
character with something that it's
getting something getting down something
deep down inside of them that's unique
to them and that's why this character
exists in this story instead of another
character
what is the nutshell technique so the
natural technique is a method that I
created it for my students and clients
to address this chronic problem I see
that 99% of writers fail to tell a story
that instead the 99% situation so all I
did is I drew up the 8 essential
elements required to successfully tell a
story created the schematic it's a
one-page schematic and these are not
beats in time
these are elements that are connected
that's what makes it different this
isn't a linear isn't a strictly linear
structure if you look at the form and
folks can download my form for my
website
Jill Chamberlain calm the key is the
connect you'll see all these little
arrows and things explain the connection
between the boxes and that's what makes
it different I'm getting that the glue
that is required to tell a story that is
required to make sure that it's not
episodic a story is not isolated events
there's a connection between them and
this gets you visually is a way for you
to see identify for small what are those
elements do you have those eight
elements in your story and then are they
working together in conjunction they
need to work together and it's about
making choices actually it's about
finding out what you're married to once
people start to because it forces you to
get things out of your head and on this
piece of paper and it's not a lot of
homework it's not like I'm asking you to
write you know a long beach gtex you
know multi-page beach sheet to explain
it's pretty brief on one page let's see
if I can identify these eight elements
first of all if you can you want to see
visually if how they're working together
and if they're not working you can see
it right on the form so it's a way of
finding out what am I married to I
really love this premise about a guy who
wakes up and it's the same day all over
again but it's not working with this
flaw that identified that he is naive
that flaw doesn't hurt this right so
which one you want to change you want to
change the floor you want to change the
great premise I probably stick with the
great premise right but then I have to
think well what would be the right
character to put in that circumstance
where they wake up and it's the same day
again yeah somebody who's naive that
wouldn't really work that's not a really
good test for them what about somebody
who's really self centric right now you
can see right on the form okay that
works much better this is gonna be a
much better test if somebody whose self
centered and self centric if they're
repeating the same day again and again
it's gonna get really boring right it's
gonna force them to start trying to do
different things and maybe finally
change and find something better in
themselves and they realize that life
isn't really worth living if you're just
living it for yourself every day right
so it's gonna take him all that time to
figure out in this journey and this test
you put him on of suddenly being caught
in a universe where he's waking up and
it's the same day again to finally face
this flaw deep down him in himself and
find a way to change and that's how he
breaks from the cycle and also play off
someone who is more naive and has I have
a sort of a write broader view of the
world yeah yeah right as a contrast that
character so it's a way of just
isolating these elements really simply
it's a very simple method really you
know very simply you can see what's
working and what's not working right
there on a piece of paper and it's just
a matter of kind of small adjustments
very often can make a huge difference
between a story first of all not working
being situation not feeling satisfying
and one that's satisfying that you know
it helps you find that unexpected and
surprising ending and satisfying way of
doing things that you're probably not
going to find otherwise if you're just
following a beat sheet method or if
you're just keeping with a situation
can you touch on briefly what those
eight elements are sure and you know and
I'll remind you that folks can also
download the forms and themselves from
my website Jill Chamberlin comm so you
can see it for yourself
but I'll point out what the elements are
so I do have a few moments in time and
byte moments in time I'm talking about
the first scene and the last scene so
we're going to identify in the first
scene what a character wants and then
we're gonna have a next moment that
identify is what I call the point of no
return this is the big event it's gonna
push us into the main part of the story
it's the event that makes this movie
this movie everything else on here is
internal to the character the point of
no return is the one moment and it's
external to the character it's the one
thing that has to happen to them so so
we're talking about Groundhog Day right
so the the point of no return is when he
wakes up and discovers it's the same day
again right and it should feel like it's
this moment makes this movie this movie
without that scene you wouldn't have the
movie Groundhog Day right it's
absolutely essential so it's important
like moment like that that's gonna drive
the rest of the story it's also external
you notice it wasn't the point of
no-return is never somebody decides to
do something there's an element of fate
that is involved when we're looking at
the point of no return so of all the
elements it's the one thing that's
external that had to happen to him he
could have not had that happen it woke
enough and it was February 3rd and then
this movie wouldn't be this movie but
for whatever reason he woke up and it
was February 2nd all over again that's
outside of his control if we were going
to look at the movie Tootsie sometimes
people say oh the point of no return is
when he goes to audition for the part
that's a choice right so the point of no
return needs to be external to the
character so I would not identify it as
he goes to audition what and what you
want to identify is the moment outside
of its control so the part where ever
really changes is when so he could have
blown that audition and he almost blows
that audition he comes very close to
blowing it but the female producer likes
him right and at one point she says I
like him I like her we're gonna hire and
she leans over and says you got the part
I'm sending the contract to your agent
that's the point of no return that
because that moments outside of his
control right that would had nothing to
do with his choice he could have blown
that audition he almost did blow that
audition but that's the moment boom now
in the movie known as Tootsie what
another thing I like to think of a great
example of this is the differences but
going from act 1 and act 2 is the Wizard
of Oz Wizard of Oz act 1 it's a black
and white point of no return is she
thinks that a tornado has lifted her
house up and dumped her in the Land of
Oz and boom weren't Technicolor we want
that feeling when we enter act 2
we're in a whole new world wait in
Kansas anymore right so it's a whole new
world there's facing it's one thing
Michael Dorsey decides to audition one
day as a woman it's another thing he's
got to fool everybody 24/7 into thinking
he's a woman that's the main story or in
Groundhog Day
he's now trapped in a cycle where every
day is Groundhog Day
that's the name part of the story so
there are two kinds of stories I talk
about in the book comedy and tragedy and
these are not these definitions don't
come from Joe blame me if you don't like
them they're from Aristotle these are
the original academic definitions of
comedy and tragedy so when I say comedy
I'm not talking about a haha comedy I'm
talking about it Aristotelian comedy and
so no Aristotelian comedy according to
Aristotle by definition is where we have
a protagonist who overcomes a flaw so
flaw is gonna be the next element I'm
going to talk about and that they're
they're going to go through change and
then eventually they're going to have a
happy ending structurally we also have
tragedies a tragedy is going to be the
opposite so we have the same set up we
have the character wants something they
get it in a point of no return but
instead of going down down down
and then coming up and having a happy
ending we're gonna go in the opposite
direction they're going to go up up up
up before they come down and have their
sad ending ninety-five percent of
stories are gonna be comedies by the way
oh yeah at least 95 percent and by the
way this applies both to feature film
and also to episodic television episode
episodic TV works structurally just like
little each episode is a like a little
mini feature film they have all of these
eight elements just like you find in a
feature film
forgive me something for interrupting
but us who then the tragedy it doesn't
necessarily mean that like a death
occurs it just means that they don't
change is that right that's right they
have a sad ending oh okay so they should
you know it they have an unhappy ending
typically but it is and it's not just an
unhappy ending
you know the way we colloquially say
that oh that's tragic in life it
probably is not the same as a tragedy in
Aristotelian sense because you might
just say something sad happens to people
they have a sad ending that's that's not
as structurally a tragedy structurally a
tragedy is because of their own flaw so
it would have to be their flaw
contributes in some way to their
downfall
so they fail to change from that flaw
and that that's part of the downfall and
and so when we're looking at the
protagonist as the the backbone there
are other elements of the story but the
nutshell we're looking at the
protagonist as the the main backbone
structurally to structure everything
around it yeah and then like I said
another major part of it was the flaw
what's the care act the flaws really the
DNA of the whole story it's a good
strong flaw as a writer as one of your
best tools to make sure your story is
strong because if you don't give your
character a strong flaw you're not
really giving them anywhere to go
that change is what the story's really
about so if we took Sunset Boulevard we
know what Norma Desmond her flaws are
but the screenwriter what were his flaws
he was desperate he was too naive he was
tricking her uh yeah so he's the
protagonist and yeah is that he's
cynical right he's cynical he
it's just a no-good writer he's always
putting himself down he's putting down
you know that voiceover that's one of
the purposes of the voiceover so for us
to hear that very cynical voice he has
where he talks about when he's reading
Norma's screenplay and he says you know
it's amazing just how bad how bad bad
writing can be right that's all
happening in voiceovers that cynical
voiceover that cynicism
is the part and that part of him that
refuses to find hope that life could be
different that actually maybe he could
find actual true love right he starts to
think he's falling in love but that
cynical voice kicks up and gets in the
way he could have been happy he could
have walked away that's what makes a
perfect tragic figure
right it's he's not a victim of
circumstances it's his own flaw that is
his downfall he could have walked away
she you know the love interest is when
he brings her to the house you know she
keeps saying I've not seen any of this
she's willing to completely forgive him
for his sordid situation let's just go
let's just leave he won't let her he
won't let her do that he forces her to
see it and then pushes her away so that
cynicism and and that cynicism the same
thing that gets him to tell Norma
revealed to Norma that where the truth
about her fan letters right those all
the fan letters she's getting are
actually being written by her ex-husband
who's the the live-in servant now right
and that and that the sessile demon
DeMille wasn't coming to see her he just
wanted the car right he still could have
survived he lost the girl but he could
have survived he could have walked out
of the door flying but he had to rub
that into some Norma Desmond's face and
that's when Norma kills him right can't
just let him walk away that's why she
shoots him in the back so but he hadn't
done that if he just said goodbye took
her suitcase and gone he would have
lived it's that that tragic flaw of
cynicism that he just can't believe that
the world could be kind enough to allow
him to have love and hope even though
everyone you know he's been giving every
opportunity of that he's got this you
know this wonderful girl who's
completely forgives him this sordid
situation
and wants to be with him despite
everything he won't have it and the fact
that the film opens with the ending hmm
is that is that something that we should
be aware of I mean it does it takes a
skilled writer to be able to get a
skilled writer yeah
well it's great when you can have a
beginning and ending image that relate
to one another I mean this uses actually
it's a very popular device now in
television I think Oh Stu Sunset
Boulevard the flash-forward which was
pretty unique in 1950 when Sunset
Boulevard was created it was kind of an
anomaly right where we had it broke all
the rules we have a narrator we have a
dead narrator and we have a story that's
in flashback those are kind of three
things you know then screen writing 101
they'll kind of warn beginning
screenwriters not to do it doesn't mean
you can't do them because look how
genius it is in Sunset Boulevard
problems it's hard to live up to
something as well as Sunset Boulevard
does but the flash-forward device of
having is become I think a really
popular advice a device for using for
television in that in television
sometimes you are has a slower pace at
that point of no-return I was talking
about happens in a feature film close to
the 25% mark in the running time feature
film sometimes it happens a little bit
later I mean I'm sorry in episodic
television it happens a little later
sometimes because we're doing so much
world building we're building you know
in a pilot episode for an entire 10 10
hour series this whole world so
sometimes it happens almost close to 50%
and in running time can we continue on
with the eight critical story elements
yeah so the story elements the next
important thing to talk about when I
talk about the point of no return in the
point of no return the character gets
something they want they also get
something they don't want and that's
gonna be what I call the catch so give
it to want but with the catch
so Michael Dorsey gets apart but he's
gonna have to dress up as a woman
in Groundhog Day Phil Conners only has
to spend 24 hours in pucks itani that
was just want but the catch is it's
actually gonna be the same 24 hours done
over and over again so the catch is
attached so it's a problem we can't just
give our character what they want
because that deflates conflict so you're
giving them something that they want
along with something they don't want and
the catch is also could be said to be
the perfect test of their flaw so the
flaw and you know Phil Conners flaw is
that he's a self centric this is the
that's the catch being that he's gonna
stop spending the same same day over and
over again it's the perfect test of
someone who is that they're
self-centered in a comedy it's gonna end
in a happy ending but they're gonna go
down down down down before because
you've got to hit rock bottom before you
can make a change so it keep in mind in
your typical ha ha comedy and your
typical ha ha comedy is an Aristotelian
comedy it's down down down now we're
laughing as bad things are happening to
the protagonists they are not laughing
they're not having a good time in act 2
of a comedy so that are going to go down
down down until they're gonna hit rock
bottom what I call their crisis the
crisis has two requirements one is it's
their absolute lowest place and then it
is the other requirement is that the
opposite of the want actually Groundhog
Day has a really interesting one in that
he's actually finally spent after being
stuck there he finally tells the truth
to Rita the love interest about what's
going on and they actually have kind of
a wonderful day together but it ends in
this very bittersweet moment where
they're falling asleep and he's says and
the terrible worst part is tomorrow
you're gonna think I'm a jerk again
and it what is wonderful about it is
this wonderful irony and that's what
we're setting up with the crisis being
the opposite this irony he only wanted
to spend 24 hours and puck so tiny how
he wishes the day could last forever
because tomorrow she'll think he's a
jerk again
so we're sending this delicious iron
there then the next thing we're going to
identify in the nutshell is we're now
entering the back three the beginning of
act 3 is the climax of your movie and
the operative word that we're going to
use though is the climatic choice at the
heart of a true climax the protagonist
is making a difficult decision
so in Groundhog Day his choice is to
start stop to stop fighting it to accept
that he's there and start trying to live
every day for the fullest and so he
becomes a really good person he starts
you know doing nice things and saving
the day and doing thinking of others
because what's the point in living and
trying to have short-term gratitude he's
got to find a different experiment with
a different way of living so he actually
starts becoming this town hero of this
person who's that known as this good guy
because he's got nothing better to do
and then finally breaks some free of the
curse and in the final step the final
step is the very last structural element
timewise the very last scene in the
movie
and now the characters gonna come to
full circle so if his flaw was that he
was self-centered he's come full circle
to its opposite strength that he now is
selfless and right because he's been
doing these things for everybody in the
town of Punxsutawney and he wakes up
that final day and he's actually it's
become February 3rd he's free of the
curse and he actually wants to stay so
those are the eight structural elements
and so like I said it's not just moments
in time this is not a beat sheet method
they are what's important is the glue
it's the the structure that holds these
pieces apart it's the connection between
these parts these are not isolated
moments in time and this is a real easy
way for writers they can use it with
they download the worksheets from my
website I also use them in my workshops
and in my private consultation we can
see right on the piece of paper what's
working what's not and if it's not
working how to adjust it by seeing that
it fits you know what what do we need to
change
in order to meet the requirements in
order to tell a story effectively once
you thought of the nutshell technique
you sat down and watched these hundred
plus movies and wrote in these notebooks
when did you actually write the book so
I created the method and I started using
it right away with my clients and
students in workshops and I've been
doing it for probably about five years
and my students kept telling me you've
got to write a book you got to write a
book and then somebody from the
University of Texas press happened to
take my workshop and said there's
nothing like your method on the
bookshelves and I said I know and he
said you should write a book proposal
and so I did and so that's how the book
came about interesting and so you kind
of put yourself in a whole new realm is
that right because now you're writing an
outline or you're querying publishers or
did Texas Press just go ahead and say
this is it
we love what you did did you have to go
through this whole process I did go
through the process I didn't approach
others you know at the time I was known
I didn't have a huge name as a script
consultant so I didn't query other
publishers I just went but I did but I
did write a proposal for University of
Texas press and had to go through that
process you know I have to say writing
the proposal was really hard I really
had to chain myself I discovered myself
having to chain myself to my desk to do
the proposal and I was really concerned
you know if I get this book deal is the
book gonna be as unpleasant as writing
the proposal because writing the
proposal I don't know what it was about
it but it was super unpleasant and
luckily it wasn't the book was much more
pleasant I think it's because in the
book I mean it's kind of similar to what
having some other screenwriters when
you're doing the proposal it's a little
bit like the beginning phases where
you're doing the the structural planning
for you know the the when you're
creating a nutshell for the screen for a
screenplay I describe it to my students
and clients as
you know spending a lot of writing days
we are kind of going and you're not
typing anything right because you're
doing all this plotting in your head and
I find it really unpleasant you know
figure that that thinking face because
you're not you want to write but you
need to think through these parts and
the book proposal is kind of similar to
that where it was like oh should I do it
this way should figure out how to
structure the book because it was very
carefully structured in the end where I
have the trying to figure out having the
nutshell diagrams in the back and having
them have a method where it's when I
referred to different nut shells in the
book I use this I use underlined to
indicate that it's going to be reflect
in the diagrams in the back and it took
a long time to figure that out how
exactly and I kind of flip flopped a
little bit in developing the proposal of
how to do this book and so it was it was
not a pleasant project process but
luckily the writing the book was
pleasant
I was curious how that was for you so
once you got sort of the green light to
go ahead and write this book did you
have a deadline that you had to have a
dead drop yeah and I was I mean that was
one of the reasons I was really glad I
was working with the publisher versus
just going self-published I'm and I
think a lot of writers will relate to
this and a lot of screenwriters I'm
terrible when I don't have a hard
deadline it's I find it much more
motivating a much more helpful to have a
firm deadline because you don't get to
make excuses you know so I'm so I think
that's you know the lesson to
screenwriters you've got to find him
even if it's an artificial deadline even
if it's a you know - in order to enter
to a competition or it's with the
writing group some sort of deadline
because if it's open-ended you'll take
forever so I had a I gave myself a
six-month deadline in to write the book
I knew that I had given myself a year I
would have taken a year but if I only
gave myself six months I could never do
it in six months and that's what I did
and so was one of the requirements they
see the full first draft or do they just
want to see section by section chapter
by chapter the full thing yeah yeah yeah
and they were okay with six months yes
interesting so then what would once you
knew this clock was ticking like what
was your day like it would or would you
do it on weekends so yeah I mean I
personally people I need to block out
town in my calendar it doesn't mean I'll
stick to it but I need to put it on the
calendar so I would put mornings
basically you know 19 oh and I'm
certainly not typing away all that whole
time but I would put you know 9 to noon
Monday through Friday unless I had
something else I had had to book then I
would try to schedule around that so
that it was on the calendar and I wasn't
writing the entire time but if it was on
the calendar that that was the time that
I blocked off for that and I tried to
move everything else around that and
then did you go and do your own outline
first did you sort of chart it out and
how did you do that that's fascinating
well I mean that was part of the book
proposal you know that was actually in
the proposal that I had to that I found
I was actually planning how I structured
the book I didn't necessarily have to do
it that way but that's the way I did it
in you know in the way I presented the
proposal it forced me to think about how
I was going to organize the book and I
tried a couple different ways before I
settled on the way I ended up doing it
which was you kind of came up with
chapters first and then well I would the
idea being that of doing I of doing the
set the idea of having all of the
nutshell chapters the nutshell diagrams
in this back section that was the piece
I couldn't quite decide how to do in the
beginning was like well maybe every time
we mention a movie we then cut to a
diagram of one of them and then what I
came up with it was having it in its own
section and that we would flip back and
forth between the two sections but it
took me a little while to come up with
that I also have a system where in the
book I use underline so when I'm I in
order to I kind of tried to structure it
a little bit like my classes where I'm
trying to repeat and emphasize things in
order to get points across and so
whenever I and to illustrate my point
when I'm so each of the chapters for
example is on each of the elements of
the nutshell so we have an app you know
I'm I flipped randomly to the chapter on
the catch and so as I go through talking
about the catch and I'll talk about
different movies how the catch works
when I refer to one of the movies that's
in the background in the back section
and I'm quoting the catch that's in the
nutshell I used a technique where I
underlined that element to it so that
you can see so the reader can very
easily see and it indicates to them oh I
could flip back so I'm looking at its
she's talking about the nutshell for
usual suspects if I want I can flip back
to here the alphabetical nutshell
section I can find usual suspects and
then I can see when she quotes it that
and she's talking about the catch that
she's actually using the exact same
wording here as I do there so that was
one very specific structural thing that
I kind of came up in the development
that I did during the proposal and was
not in a Ridge that was not the way I
originally thought about doing the book
there were a couple different ways and
trying to figure out how to do it so
let's say I'm a screenwriter and I email
you and I say I need my script fixed
ASAP they and we agreed to work together
what are the first things you're looking
at you know I'm kind of simultaneously
looking on both a macro and a micro
level so I as I'm going
ultimately ultimately the story is of
ultimate of the utmost importance but
I'm also as I'm reading on the page
noting things so I mark things up as I
go so I may question things or I may
already have suggestions that have to do
with sometimes minor kind of things or I
can think of a better phrasing or you
know your action description isn't clear
enough especially those first ten pages
where which are super important if I'm
getting I'm having a really hard time
slogging through those that's a really
bad sign so I might even spend a fair
amount more time trying to point that
out to help you so I'm looking at the
micro-level
I'm also ultimately kind of sitting back
and looking at the macro-level how does
the story work and and I often don't
know the answer to that till I get to
the very end I'm kind of doing two
things at once and then at what point do
you send them notes and do they have to
make changes for you to review or it's
up to them whether they want to make
those changes so I what I do is I meet
with the writer either person or via
Skype and I have their script marked up
but I don't do written notes I don't do
a written report unless you want to pay
for that separately which I don't
recommend I don't think that's a very
efficient use of your money
I mean I'll probably do it if you want
to pay me by the hour to sit and type up
a report I don't think that's a very
time efficient use of your money I think
it's much more efficient if we have so
with each of my consultations it
includes 60 to 90 minutes where we talk
either in person or via Skype so I go
through on the page you know pointing
out things but also talking story I also
find it it's also it's not just that
it's time inefficient that for me to
type up a report is that the to do that
is not a two-way thing so it's more
efficient for me to be able to start to
ask you questions and try to find out
what you were something's not working
try to figure out what it was you were
trying to do versus being doing some
sort of detached coverage report that's
just not a very useful tool for the
writer you want as a writer you want to
know how can I make this better so the
way to make it better is for us to talk
about it let's just talk about oh well
if that's what you're trying to do oh I
totally did not get that that was the
characters flaw you need to let's look
at you know this very first scene and
see if you can adjust if that's the flaw
they should be saying this in the first
scene so we're gonna look at you know
specifics so I'm really kind of script
doctoring and trying to help you know
I'm not just giving you a passive report
that tells you thumbs up or thumbs down
that's it's not very useful - who cares
what if I think it's thumbs up or thumbs
down
you want to know job is to make your
script as good as it can possibly be so
I like to have that two-way conversation
we can talk about oh that's what you're
trying to do if you're trying to I
didn't not get that at all if you're
trying to do that you need to bring it
up in moments like this let's you know I
want to hear that if the characters
flaws that they're jealous they should
be saying that in this moment or they
should try doing this so there's a
two-way conversation that happens there
and are most people receptive to when
you want to make changes or that you can
suggest them I would say 97% of the time
right nineteen ninety-seven percent of
the time they are and they're and and
and and that's why I generally love my
job right is that you know people pay me
to tell them what works and doesn't work
in their script and they say oh my god
thank you that's such a good suggestion
and they love it and they go with it and
then there's the 3% who I don't know if
they think I'm a run a studio or
something I'm some sort of date like not
you know there are occasionally unhappy
that I you know that and it's you know
this isn't a productive thing you're not
trying to convince me you know why
you're trying to convince me your script
doesn't work when I'm telling you it
doesn't work right I'm trying to help
you help you so that you can make it
work so occasionally you find someone
who's resistant that was funny because
that just prompts something in my mind
about I was watching an interview with
Errol Morris it was an older interview
and he said most people actually don't
see themselves as they are and actually
other people are better gauges at who
they are you know that that cliche you
know I know you better than you know
yourself I've always hated that that
expression but he said that that's
actually kind of true especially in
retelling of his things do you think
that's true with writers that they don't
you mean as far as their ability or you
know I'm actually surprised that they
kind of for the most part in the reason
why 97% of them are receptive is that
deep down they do know that and that's
why most of them go well is that they're
not generally shocked at what I'm gonna
say you might be disappointed they might
have expected it hoped that they tried
this thing and that it's you know it
worked and it didn't but they're not
shocked they're kind of like yeah I kind
of suspected it and so I'm just there
you know and and they're trying and
that's part of the
some of the things you're gonna try work
and you'll be and I'll tell you that and
you'll be pleasantly surprised and then
other ones aren't going to work and it's
going to confirm what you may be
suspected but that's the point of
getting the draft done and on paper and
out of your head so that someone you
know I'll have a professional read it so
you can find out what works and what
doesn't work and something zeal surprise
yourself and do better than you thought
and some things not as well so for the
most part people actually aren't so
surprised you know it's it's I think
those are the three percent are the ones
who have are ones who do have a
different dis connect in their head
about what it what it is and how it's
working 97% of people don't they kind of
they hope I love every single word but
when I point out something we're like
yeah I kind of knew that wasn't working
and so it was you know it resonates with
them do you think writers are very
self-aware or they're just they've been
critiqued so much what they're writing
through school or classes that they've
taken whatever that they just kind of
know yeah I realize I'm not doing active
voice here I'm doing Pat you know well I
don't know what do you think it is you
know it varies at their level it varies
it how often they've been critiqued it
varies it the kind of Gucci's and I see
all different levels I you know where
people are quite self-aware and and are
used to criticism and they're not going
to be defensive and they know the things
and they'll say it right I won't have a
point you know that out a weakness
they're like yeah I'm not great at doing
action sequences and then there are
others who are our self is we're a
self-aware it really depends
do beat sheets work I think having an
outline is an excellent idea I do know
writers who don't need them I think that
needs something in and these are going
to be writers I speak of writers I've
worked with so they are tend to already
be devotees of using the nutshell
technique and that might be all they do
they won't do a me cheat they'll just do
a nutshell technique form and as long as
they are true to that they'll have it
and it's nice and solid and maybe
they'll work with me one on one to make
sure they're there nutshell is solid
little tack it up on their bulletin
board and then they'll write from that
and they don't do any other beat sheet
or outlining I think most writers need a
beat sheet or outline they need more
detail than that but it varies as long
as you so as long as you have a solid
structure you don't necessarily need
more than this
you know the idea this isn't drawn to
scale but you'll see that most of my
structure things are in act 1 and act 3
and the only thing that's an act 2 is
just one element here and act 2 is
actually twice as long so I don't have a
bunch of structure requirements I don't
have required beats in your act to even
act - even though act 2 is twice as long
I strongly believe that if you properly
structure things in act 1 and you
properly structure things in act 3 it
does all the heavy lifting of supporting
your act - even though your act 2 is
twice as long as long as you maintain
conflict so I know lots of writers who
hate meat sheets and and ask me can I
really throw it out I was like you
absolutely can if you don't like doing a
beachy you don't find that helpful you
can as long as you find a nice solid
structure and you stay true to it this
should be enough to guide you as long
seem to have conflict I do think most
writers need more detail and so I you
know but it it it's up to the right or a
little bit so more detail I don't I
don't think it's a good idea to do a
super detailed one because you want to
allow a certain amount of discovery on
the page
I mean that's why I like having the
looser structure of the nutshell to
begin with we have a couple things you
gotta hit if it shifts from them then
you're screwing up a story but if you
say solid to these elements that might
not might be all you need and you could
just write and live on the page as long
as you hit those couple of moments or
perhaps you need a little bit more
structure a little bit of an outline or
a beat sheet but I don't recommend doing
super detailed ones there's a thing I
call beat sheet fatigue where people
just spend too much time on that
particular if you're getting feedback if
you're sharing if you're nutshell you're
you're I'm sorry you're beat sheet or
your outline with your writing group or
people like that you maybe get feedback
on maybe like an eight page one but
anything longer than that it's getting
into so much detail but we'd rather read
the script at that point you know a beat
sheet ultimately is for your benefit
anyway so what it's whatever you need if
you need a little more structure than
just this and like I said I think most
people need a little bit more I think
it's a pretty good idea to have a loose
guide of you know this happens I think
this happens then this happens in this
happens but kind of loose so that you
can discover somewhat on the page what
about conflict fatigue what about
someone adding too much conflict right
away but there's no real purpose it's
just it's just creating friction because
the writer thinks they need it but then
it doesn't really lend itself to the
story do you see that a lot or do you
see not enough conflict I see not enough
a complet conflict more often as a
problem what you're describing there
being too much it sounds to me like it
would be the case of somebody who hadn't
really figured out what the story is and
they're just they just know screenwriter
101 it's just a conflict right so they
just have a bunch of conflict but
there's not necessarily a purpose so it
sounds like that might be a little
situational or episodic but I'd have to
kind of see that in the case bike
that basis I saw a headline on
medium.com the other day and the woman
was writing about something to the
effect of stop calling yourself an
aspiring writer you are a writer how do
you feel about that for new writers well
the question would be but are you
writing
if you're writing then I agree don't
call yourself an aspiring writer I do
however meet a fair number of aspiring
writers and I talked to them and I asked
you know how many scripts have you
written and well they haven't written
one yet
you know then I would say they're still
aspiring you've got if you want to be a
writer you have to write I mean
writings work it's it's it sounds sexy
it sounds it we're least two writers it
sounds sexy you know it's a sexy idea in
our mind the actuality is not sexy at
all it's work you're gonna you have to
sit there you know it's about moments
alone on the page and dealing with it so
I agree with the writer as long as
you're if you're writing then you
shouldn't belittle yourself by calling
yourself aspiring but if you're still
just dreaming about it and liking the
idea of being a writer but you're not
actually doing anything about it
then I think I'm afraid you're an
aspiring writer okay fair enough
what if they're just journaling is that
a writer I mean I think a lot of people
have found that a useful tool for
getting the juices going for exploring
things I don't know that I feel
comfortable labeling them one way or
another I think at some point they're
gonna have to translate it to something
just another medium probably find a way
you know are what they're journaling is
that something that that will inspire a
screenplay or a short story or a poem or
is it just a diary and last part of this
question what if they are actually
writing short store
or scripts but with no intention of
anyone seeing them except themselves and
their cat or your dog
whoever's let's and I think that's fine
and they can call themselves a writer I
had B I'm surprised at that you know
it's I mean I think it's hard enough I
mean that's one of the frustrations
about being a writer particularly
screenwriter is that we're writing
something that is so far even under the
best of circumstances from being made it
into something it's several steps away
so I would question that person about
why why are they content sharing it just
with their cat if they are then if it
makes them happy then that's absolutely
fine and I you know I certainly
experienced I do have students who say
you know this is the one one respite
from maybe a unhappy job you know in a
life in some ways that is not filled
with joy that that that's the one time
they really get to explore and that they
do feel joy is is writing and that's
completely valid I just want them to
encourage to share it with with the
world but that's up to them
do facts make good stories facts are
tricky so I think the hardest stories to
break are ones that are based on
real-life events and I have a philosophy
a little bit with my students and
clients that I tell them when it comes
to research I say Wikipedia it and be
done
the more you know sometimes is a problem
actually now that's gonna work with some
stories better than others you know you
can have a lot more freedom if you're
going to write if you're writing about
William Wallace where there are very few
written records at that time and you
could have an enormous amount of freedom
and and with something like Braveheart
because we knew virtually very little
about the man versus if you're going to
do a story about a you know about Elton
John you know someone who's actually you
know in the who's living in whose facts
a lot of a lot of us know you're gonna
you're gonna have to you can't have as
much leeway necessarily so it is harder
to make true life stories work as
stories because again remember life is a
situation life itself is not a story so
you're gonna have to find ways to
structure things and from maximum impact
in order to tell a story
I had a experience once where I was at a
party and a student introduced me to a
prominent documentary filmmaker who I
won't name okay and and when and she
introduced me and you know as her
screenwriting teacher and the author of
this book that's about screenwriting
story structure and his attitude was a
little bit like yeah structure schmuck
sure and I said to him you know well let
me understand you you know when you make
your documentary films are they just to
our interviews with no cuts
at all do you employ editing do you have
cuts and just like yeah of course it was
like okay well if you employ editing if
you have cuts you're using structure
that's all structure is structure is
about choosing what events you show in
the order that you show them in and what
at the vents you don't show that's all
it is so we can manipulate real-life
events to an extent and that's what
we're gonna have to do unless you wanted
to show a two-hour interview up with
absolutely no cuts if you know you are
if your documentary film is telling a
story you're gonna have to have cuts and
you're gonna have to choose which
moments to show on which moments you cut
away from and and which moments you
don't show some true life events are
more easily can be made into stories
than others some it's gonna be very
difficult so I can't promise when people
you know come in and that they're doing
something on a biographical figure that
it's necessarily going to work and
sometimes you know I can sympathize with
them the trouble but if we can't find
certain patterns and some some some
people's lives its it dramatically may
not make for a good story unfortunately
but the less we know about them the
better because then we can make up more
or we can be more you know the less that
there are living figures involved and we
can speculate about for example what the
protagonists flaw was and you know it
doesn't mean that we're radically
changing from the truth but if it's not
a figure we know so much about we can be
a little more flexible about choosing
the elements that most enhance the
real-life events in order to to show a
pattern that could show a story when you
explain some of that to the filmmaker
what was their response I get a little
of this but I wonder if maybe it stayed
with them we'll see
he said easier to fix a story in the
beginning or just write a proper story
rather than fix it later on it's much
easier to fix in the beginning yeah it's
much easier that's why I encourage
people to get involved with me or script
consultant as early as possible you know
bring me in the story breaking process I
really I have a longtime clients who
view me as a coach really when they have
a new idea as soon as they get the idea
they'll call me up to make an
appointment and will they're like I want
to you know maybe they're writing
something else but that's other stories
kind of you know bugging them and then
when I like get a handle on it and
figure out the story nutshell and they
can set it aside and then they can focus
on the story they're supposed to be
writing but it's much easier to start to
try to get a handle on that early on we
could do it later and lots of people do
that way a lot of people you know how
bring me in after they've written a
script it's a first draft or maybe it's
a few drafts in it's just gonna be and
we can fix it it's just gonna be harder
you know it's you get a little more
attached to your babies right and you're
a little less willing to throw things
out if you're you know get the feedback
I'm like oh this whole second act you
went in the wrong direction you know
it's a little can be a tough pill to
swallow sometimes that you're gonna have
to almost go back to the drawing board
right so it's it's just easier to have
have someone working with you who is
thinking from about story from an
outside protect perspective and can help
you before you've you've started getting
invested in creating and got into the
world and you're creating scenes and all
these moments that may or may not
actually work because you didn't really
think through what flaw was and that's
gonna change everything and make you
have to rewrite the whole thing so do
you advise people sometimes take the
same idea and just start from page one
like just take that script put it
somewhere you love the idea whatever you
love the protagonist let's start over
from the
that's a painful thing to tell people
right I will I think more common is that
they have some good bones maybe in the
first act and then it kind of derailed I
think is what I see you know what I mean
because that they have a sense of the
character and they have a maybe an
interesting point of no-return that's
gonna begin the main story but then I'm
suggesting some major changes in kind of
almost yeah putting aside your act to
enact three that that's a little more
typical than than a page one because if
they've gone through writing it even if
the even if the draft isn't working it
is about exploring story it is about
them exploring the character and it's
not likely that they created nothing of
worth along the hundred twenty pages
that they wrote so that's why it would
be a little unusual for me to say yeah
just throw out the whole thing let's go
back to two to page one it's more like
you started it and it derailed it is a
little bit more typical what I see
what's your favorite chapter in the book
like one that you're especially proud of
or a topic that just really gets you
going you know though what one of my
favorites is the one in the flaw because
I think the flaw is so important I think
it may be the longest chapter in the
book and I loved writing about it
and it just is an area that it's like
the one tool I can give a new writer
right off the bat that will make a huge
improvement and a lot of writers don't
know anything about it and it really is
the most fundamental you know important
thing for story building to realize the
importance of having a really strong
flaw and it's a rookie mistake sometimes
I see the characters they didn't even
know that their protagonist was supposed
to have a flaw right we're not used to
thinking about our heroes as having
flaws they're not flawed everybody else
is the one that's screwed up
yeah but if everyone else is screwed up
then you're making your pataga
it's just a victim of these things
happening right it's a deeper level to
start thinking about what is what is the
flaw in them that is actually making
their problem worse and I that's one of
the favorite my favorite things to talk
about with writers to explore it's just
one of the most fundamental things to
understanding who the character is is
that one single thing the flaw so it's
the longest chapter I try to explore it
the most and and I think it's one of the
most things that will give writers the
most yield as far as understanding story
and characters to really give some
thought as to what is my protagonist
central flaw whether certain movies you
recommend that they watch that show an
especially flawed character oh I love
movies with flawed characters leaving
Las Vegas III still I would I havn't
nutshell that movie but I would argue
that rights would be a tragedy I would
argue argue that it didn't have a
satisfying enough second act up turn but
I'd have to go back and look at it to
see I like movies that are more
technically comedies so structurally
that means they have a happy ending but
it have a really flawed characters
because I think it's it's it's really
easy and not very interesting to have
likable characters but how much more
delicious is it to have a really
unlikable character right and then by
the end you get us cheering for them
that's really good writing so I'll point
out one movie that I love for that
reason is the movie the verdict
it's a Paul Newman movie prime and this
guy you've heard of he's a lawyer
you've heard of ambulance chasers oh yes
this guy is a hearse chaser oh wow he
crashed his funerals went under the
pretense of having no
the the deceased he and he just finds
them in obituaries he preys on these
unsuspecting widows trying to get work
he's such a hardcore alcoholic that he
can't pick up his morning shot with his
donut without the shakes he's got a lean
over at one point to drink that at one
point he punches a woman in the face
it's characters unbelievably unlikable
but by the end of the movie we're
rooting for the sky hmm that's amazing
screenwriting
that's amazing screenwriting right well
you can get us to care about this guy
and we do we really care that's that's
the the depth of how great the
screenwriting isn't how great the
performance too is one of polynomials
greatest performances so I love
unlikable characters that you can get us
to like by the end that tells you
something
so really flawed characters like that I
another interesting movie to me a more
recent example is flight okay and from
me what was really interesting so we're
very L call it character make good
characters up they know nicely flawed
characters they're great that's a great
flaw and by the way alcoholism is not a
flaw but for our purposes you want to
find what's the under lying flaw so it's
gonna be different for different
alcoholics the the alcoholic and the
verdict he has no sense of self-worth in
flight this alcoholic has this
incredible sense of entitlement right so
it's gonna be different you want to dig
deeper find out what is the the flaw
underneath it and what I love about
flight it has the most it's a wonderful
example of an incredibly surprising yet
satisfying third act and I'm not I guess
I don't want to give spoilers so if
someone hasn't seen it but I'll just say
that the character the protagonist is in
we think he's gonna get we want him to
get off scot-free
because we we are rooting for this guy
even though he's an alcoholic and he's
got a lot of
shoes and we kind of know he shouldn't
go free and things don't go the best
possible way but it's incredibly
surprising and satisfying and so it's it
has a really unusual particular like a
Hollywood movie I think a really unusual
third act and ending where we have a
character under outward circumstances
you wouldn't say on paper that sounded
like a happy ending and yet he's the
happiest we've seen him the whole movie
even though things didn't go his way
when I look at a lot of Humphrey Bogart
movies he seems to play the same
character all of which is enjoyable to
watch but I don't see him especially
flawed maybe I haven't seen all of them
so there's others he's made me very very
confident
definitely arrogant but what do you
think a lot of times is his his flaw
that he needs to overcome because I see
him is like you know he's got to push
women away I mean they're like falling
all over him so what what is this far
well I I think I'm gonna criticize
Humphrey Bogart a little bit okay that I
like him but there is something in the
way and I try not to blame actors too
much does he never know what all was
going on so I'll say the way he was
directed in that he's a little too
reserved so much in some ways someone
actually on Amazon I noticed docked me a
point they liked my book a lot but they
they didn't like that I pointed out that
it had Casablanca followed my method it
would have been a better movie and they
they they took off a star or that and
and and to them I would say yeah but I'm
not wrong it would have been a little
bit better that there's something a
little bit too reserved about him
and so Casablanca I think it's a great
movie but it does feel a little dated
and I think a lot of modern audiences
particularly younger people don't even
get what happened and I think part of it
is a little bit of Humphrey Booker it's
the way he was directed then he's a
little bit too much reserved and also it
was missing and this is the what I was
recommending in my book it was missing
Sene I felt where we we needed to hear
his enter his inner struggle with what
was going on and he is you know he
doesn't articulate that what happened
the dilemma he has of having to the fact
that he has the whole the weight of the
whole world's fate is on his shoulders
he doesn't articulate that and he's also
directed in such a way that we don't
really get what's going on behind the
mask when it's so it's we have to read
behind we have to read between the lines
quite a bit and I think that's what's
what what's really powerful about
Casablanca unfortunately you have to
read between the lines of that this this
man who has you know his flaw is that he
has become cynical and that he has lost
faith in the world now has the weight of
the whole world is looking towards him
from making this to you know this
decision that literally the the fate of
World War two lies in the balance a
little bit but we're given kind of the
Humphrey Bogart mask a little bit and
and nor does he say it in dialogue nor
is he an actor that you know as someone
who wears the heart on a sleeve so it's
a little hard to pick up sometimes is
his flaw sure words to take Jimmy
Stewart's character
oh yeah life exerts on the sleeves
that's a great example yeah I was trying
to think of who would be the good or the
right one but something like a Jimmy
Stewart exactly right you could imagine
him at the crisis of Casablanca you know
having to do this you would feel his
pain alright and we don't really
humphrey bogart won't let us feel his
pain right and I guess that was part of
maybe that type of man at that time more
concern more reserved nothing got to him
in you know sort of impenetrable or and
I'm saying the word wrong but you know
just this sort of like tough outer shell
that you're trying to crack and you know
yeah what's in there and so yeah but we
wanted to see it at least at some moment
late and that my suggestion was that we
haven't we do had that one moment where
he's crying to Sam he gets drunk and
he's kind of crying to Sam about about
and drunk about what happened and shove
all the bars she had to come back in
mind you know and I would have reserved
that moment and had him do that at the
crisis to be upset and drunk and say
that to Sam right because that's such an
important important moment but we don't
we don't get to know that because he's
got that that tough outer shell so they
did let it crack through and I
understand you probably don't want to
scenes of that cracking through but I
would had it crack through at the moment
of the crisis because that's the really
powerful moment that people don't get
the sacrifice he's going through we
don't get it because he has such a tough
outer shell so the writers start with
character or plot you know I sometimes
say that there are two kinds of writers
the ones that start with character and
the one that is start with plot I think
both are valid ways I think however and
if someone starts with character I
wouldn't tell them that they're long and
that they shouldn't I think if you start
with plot it's a little easier to to
break story and to work with story so
like the example I was saying with
Groundhog Day you know if you start with
the premise is far more interesting than
the character
what if somebody woke up and it was the
same day a second time that's a great
premise right I want to start with that
then ask myself well who'd be the most
interesting character to put in that
what if it was somebody who's naive that
that probably wouldn't work what if it
was somebody was a jerk
now and that helps me build the plot and
the character right so for me it works
much more naturally and it's much more
easy to work with story to start that
way that said I know a lot of people
start with character
they love to explore character that's
you know and for a variety of reasons
sometimes they came from an acting
background and and that's part of acting
training sometimes I'd like to get
inside a character's head maybe they're
doing a biographical figure and then you
kind of have to in a way you are
starting with the character and but you
then need to decide what plot moments do
I want to use to help show this
characters change and what plot moments
am I going to leave out but then you
kind of necessarily are starting with
character but generally speaking if I
had to pick the two of the two I would
say plot is the most easy to manipulate
manipulate in to build story around and
to make sure you're you're creating a
satisfying story start with that great
premise what if this happened and then
ask yourself okay now who would be the
most interesting character to put into
that dilemma just to delve more into
flaw flaw is the direct opposite of
strength yeah
so on my nutshell technique form I pose
as two opposites you know what is the
character central flaw and then what is
the strength that in the end in a comedy
they either learn the opposite of or in
a tragedy was the strength that they
fail to learn the opposite of one thing
I note sometimes if it's hard time so
people have multiple flaws you know we
don't have just one flaw but typically
they only learn one thing so sometimes
when I'm working with a writer and they
have a hard time identifying you know
what is the flaw is that insecurity is
that lack of self-worth is it you know a
couple we might bad about a couple
things sometimes I try not to pick one
necessarily until we look at the third
act and see if it's comedy and see well
what is the what is the message what is
this the thing that they are changing to
because all three of those flaws we
mentioned may be the case but they were
probably only discovered one opposite
strength because we typically in a at
least in a story are only going to
discover one thing
so what in the third act we see that
they're finally discovered the sense of
self-worth
so we'll identify that as the nutshell
flaw its opposite that they had a lack
of self-worth even though they may also
be insecure and have some other flaws
but you want to ultimately when you're
using the nutshell technique form you
want to phrase those as two direct
opposites and there should be direct
opposites so if we were gonna you know
call in Tootsie we're gonna say that he
is his flaw is a misogynist then we'd
have to identify what is the direct
opposite of that would be not even sure
what that would be someone who who has I
would end up saying something like
respect for women so it's a meet or
opposite then just say the flaw is lack
of respect of women instead of
misogynist just so that they're clean
opposites so I kind of massage will work
with the writer sometime to massage them
so that we have nice clear opposites so
they shouldn't just be vaguely one's
positive ones negative they should this
should be direct opposites whatever they
are and in the case of the tragedy I
think it's important to we also identify
the strength that they failed to learn
so the idea in a tragedy is that the
reason why they have the tragic ending
is because they failed to change from
the flaw so we use on the same form we
identify what would that strength be
it's just that we can imagine in our
minds I had they gained had Joe Gillis
and Sunset Boulevard discovered hope
instead of being cynical then we can
kind of imagine okay now I see how that
would have been a happy ending right how
do you discovered that then he would
have accepted when the love interest
says I haven't heard any of this let's
just go he would have said you're right
let's just go so it's important to
identify go ahead and put into words
what is that strength even though the
point is in a tragedy they don't achieve
that strength they stay flawed but what
would have changed their destiny
had they discovered it because we should
feel that we should feel that in that
what makes a satisfying tragedy
tragedies are tricky but I think they
can be very satisfying when we have to
feel like oh oh if he'd done that oh I
can feel I can just almost taste it that
he could have actually discovered that
opposite strength that I can imagine
that happy ending that would have
happened on a subconscious level we feel
that with with Sunset Boulevard that's
why it works when he makes that choice
to rub betty space and it were like oh
why are you doing that why are you doing
that you had your chance right that's
what we're feeling we're feeling that
hope that hope he should have had but
that flaw just took them over sure but
without that it doesn't feel satisfying
it just feels forced
if we don't if we're not conscious about
if someone's just doing tragic things
without reason I'm just wondering about
films that have multiple flawed
characters I'm thinking of like The
Breakfast Club and I guess you could say
if I remember correctly Judd Nelson is
like the protagonist I'm trying to
remember because there's so many voices
in that but how is that dealing with
multiple flawed characters if they're
flawed from the beginning we know
they're flawed they're in detention how
does that work well I would say first of
all if a movie successfully tells a
story only one of them is technically
the protagonist and let me mention
that's a tool for the writer audience
doesn't need to know that audience can
think it's a you know it's an ensemble
picture and that there isn't a
protagonist that's fine let them think
it's an ensemble picture it's for you
the writer to structure stories to know
yeah but secretly Judd Nelson's the
protagonist right and and this is good
news for you as a writer because only
one character has to truly have a
nutshell that a hundred percent works so
the other characters may and generally
we're going to want to see that you know
if it is story that it's a structure
structurally an Aristotelian comedy
we're gonna want to see most of the
characters make a change flawed or
strength but only one of them has to
have all the nutshell elements work it's
just going to make your life easier
so the other characters may have
interesting for you know the flawed
strength that's their character art but
structurally you can know well secretly
just this one character is truly the
protagonist and that's the backbone and
then it's gonna be easier to let all the
other pieces fall into place and again
it's for the writers benefit audience
doesn't audience can think it's an
ensemble picture audience can tell their
friends oh no there's no protagonist
it's an ensemble picture that's fine let
them think that what's the difference in
the nutshell technique with film versus
television yes so the natural technique
actually applies to television pretty
much exactly the same as it does to
feature film and it's per episode some
people ask me well I thought characters
aren't supposed to change in television
is is the nutshell over the course of
the season or series it's a myth that
characters don't change in television
it's an absolute myth if you look at the
pilot episode of Breaking Bad the very
first episode of Breaking Bad he goes
from being a very clearly mild-mannered
meek science teacher to in the very
first episode tries to kill two people
very first episode he makes 75% of his
exchange over the entire course of the
series in that first episode so it's a
real myth that characters don't change
in TV one difference I'll say with
comedies in ha comedy sitcoms same thing
they change the difference is the next
episode they completely forgot what they
learned they have a bit of a reset and
so the next episode it's like they
forgot what they learn but we're seeing
I see in episodic television per
episodes complete nut shells so episodic
television
each episode needs to be a complete
story in and of itself so if you were to
tune in into the middle of season 2 of a
show and watch a random episode it
should feel some good you know for a
decent TV show the episode itself right
should feel
satisfying it needs to tell a story so
for television you need to have a
complete nutshell but on top of that you
have to have that thing we know is legs
so that thing that's pulling us into
this the next episode so the episode the
pilot episode of Breaking Bad in and of
itself is a very set really is and I
urge people to think of it think of it
as little mini feature films when you
watch TV the next time you watch an
episode episodic show watch the episode
and ask yourself doesn't it have that
beginning middle and end in a complete
story it doesn't have all of those
nutshell changes don't we see one of the
characters go from a flaw to its
opposite strength within that episode so
it needs to be that so that episode the
pilot episode of Breaking Bad if you
just saw the episode in itself it's
pretty satisfying in one way plus it's
got the legs of like we know it's not
over there's more coming but if you saw
the episode in yourself it's actually
got a quite a satisfying ending to it
what are the five biggest mistakes
screenwriters make well I don't know if
I'm gonna do five off the top of my head
but I will say under estimating the
importance of structure a good structure
is you know I feel like that's one two
three and four right is is gonna paint
the way it's going to it is the story
structure is story right I was not you
know well that the William Goldman is
the one who said that it is determining
character development so all of those I
really do think one through four are the
importance of structure and then if I
had to say a fifth thing I want to say
it's sort of a contradictory thing that
you need to be both tougher on yourself
and you need to be easier on yourself
that I see writers do things like
they'll say to a friend you know maybe a
friends more accomplished writer than
they are and they'll say you know I
finished my draft would you read it it's
not very good
why are you bothering your friend the
worst writer to read your draft that's
not very good
uh-huh right you need to you need to put
a little more effort into it you need to
be a little harder on yourself you
should think your draft is very good
before you are opening it up for
feedback right you're kind of wasting
the expertise of those around you if
you're sharing drafts when you don't
think they're very good at the same time
you kind of need to be easier on
yourself so be harder on yourself in the
sense that did don't bug your friend
until your script is in a good place but
but also be kind to yourself that you
know there's a lot of what makes people
successful is luck is dumb luck you know
and they're people who are more
challenging than you that are successful
other people who less talented than you
that are successful so give yourself a
break that no no script is going to be
perfect even a great writer can and I've
seen writers kind of killed themselves
doing Draft after Draft after draft
obsessing and getting contradictory
notes and then they don't know what
they're doing and that and driving
themselves crazy because they're being a
little too hard on themselves at some
point you got to let it be you you got a
you know once you feel good about it
you've done some good drafts on it you
feel good you've gotten some good
feedback from your writing group or
people you trust not everyone's gonna
like it got to put it out in the world
and relax you know and somebody you
you're gonna get some notes back that
aren't what you agree with don't obsess
about it and try to because you can't
please everyone with your book the
nutshell technique which chapter is most
debated by people whether it's a
friendly debate or whether it's outright
people have these very severe beliefs
about I'll say the most confusion is the
concept of the watt right so the very
first thing I talk about is that in the
first scene the character has something
that they will want but they get in the
point of no return this is the trickiest
piece for some reason and I have two
chapters on it's actually the only
element I devote two chapters to for
this reason I try to and this is just
from years of experience that I've
learned this I try to help people by
calling it and explaining and it's still
and yet still there's confusion about
this this one that I'm talking about
here I call it the set up want it is not
necessarily the character's greatest
want it is not necessarily the
character's biggest motivation and and
yet people still do that that they still
think it's well my character wants one
thing and according to Jill's nutshell
technique they have to get it in the
point of no return but that doesn't work
with my point of no return
my point that I've tried to make clear
is that your character just like your
character has multiple flaws they have
multiple things that they want there's
not a one-to-one really
between watts appointive no returns your
character wants multiple things all I'm
saying is that there's one watt that
they get in the point of no return it
may not be their biggest wand
it may not be their defining one it may
not be the thing that they say that they
want it's just something they want so I
call it sometimes I call it a throwaway
want sometimes your character just wants
a sandwich all we're doing is we're
setting up this little piece I call this
be careful what you wish for what
happens in the point of no return
so be careful and don't think that that
makes a movie not applied to the nut
shell technique because you
it didn't seem like the character got
what they wanted I talked about in
Groundhog Day
his most obvious it's because it's a
great example of this point his most
obvious what he talks about in the first
scene he thinks that there's a network
that's scouting him for a big Network
job right that's his most obvious one he
wants a big Network job he doesn't get
that blonde right I'm not saying he
doesn't want it he says he wants it
I believe him it's just not the setup
blonde so you need to look and find
something else that the character wants
that they get so I'm not negating the
fact that Phil Connor wants a network
job I'm not negating the fact that Phil
Connor wants women to worship Him he
wants lots of things he's not gonna get
just like we all want lots of things we
don't get the thing that he wants that
he gets it's a little throwaway line he
says basically that he doesn't want to
spend more than 24 hours in PUC cet'aeni
it's a little throwaway line matter of
fact it wasn't in the three versions of
the screenplay that I looked at at
researching this for this book
interesting yeah it was very late in the
process that they also discovered we're
missing something we're missing
something that makes Phil even Phil this
jerk isn't a victim of the universe
suddenly making him stuck on one day he
kind of in the original drafts was kind
of a victim of just this thing happened
him
stuck the writers at a very latent
process because it's not in the three
scripts I've seen but some place between
those three drafts and the movie it was
shot
they added a scene where he says to the
substitute weather man who's once wants
to spend more time covering for him when
he's in when he's in pucks Otani Hill
says please like I want to spend an
extra second in pucks a time it's a
throwaway line I don't want to spend
more than 24 hours in pucks tetani
we're just setting up be careful what
you wish for because he got his why he
only has to spend 24 hours in pucks
itani right except for there's a big
catch he's gonna have to spend the same
24 hours over and over again
so the want is a setup one I put it I
call it a set want with quotes around it
it's not necessarily the characters big
want can we use an example from
Chinatown okay Jack Nicholson's
character like an initial want he meets
Faye Dunaway yeah what's his first like
one want that he gets that's not really
his real want well I don't know but I'll
tell you what the real one is though it
so the set up one we're gonna find in
the literally their first scene so it's
before he meets Faye Dunaway it would be
in that very first scene when he's got
curly sitting across from him Curly's
that client he's showing the pictures of
curly as with the cheating cheating
who's been cheating on him right and
curlies like sobbing all over the place
right so what he wants is what he
doesn't have here he wants a classic
case cuz this you know cheating wives
thing is not really classy so what he
wants it's a classic case want something
classic than what he's getting
he gets that in the the main case that's
gonna be Chinatown the catch is it's got
corruption all over it right he's a lot
bigger than he thought it was it's not
even the wife Yeah right
interesting okay yeah just so that's
that's kind of his his initial want yeah
he wants a class your case he thinks he
gets it he gets this femme fatale that
comes in
turns out it's a whole mess of trouble
but he doesn't realized that yeah yeah
right so the one Reverend it's a throw
it's a throwaway thing that it they say
interesting you know in Juno's got
another nice example I talked about in
the book that the wat is it's a really
clever one actually where it's the scene
where she's drinking the SunnyD because
she's taking the pregnancy test and
she's trying to pee oh right she's
drinking the Sunny D she's and she sees
an old discarded chair somebody left on
out on the curb and that reminds her of
like it puts her flash back of her
having sex with Polly the moment that
got her pregnant
and the thing that she wants she's just
looking at a chair she wants to save
something that's being discarded the
chair that she pulls and she puts on
Polly's lawn is sort of this active
right and then what's that how does she
save something that's being discarded at
the point of no return what's the point
of no return in Juno do you remember I
don't it's been a few years is it
something with her babysitting job no
she is planning she goes she's pregnant
she goes for an abortion that's wrong
she can't go through the abortion that's
right so she's gonna save something that
was about to be discarded a fetus so
what we're doing is you're getting your
walk but you're getting it with ironing
right in the beginning she just wanted
to save a chance right okay right so
she's and it fritz I call it a throwaway
want and yet it also fits with her
character really nicely she's someone
who kind of saves discarded things she
has a hamburger phone you know and
people like Polly who sort of discarded
so it's very fitting in a character she
wants to save this discarded living room
set but then she goes to save a fetus
that she was thought she could discard
and discovers that's a lot harder than
she thought it was going to be what
mistakes to screenwriters make was
structure invariably screenwriters are
failing to tell a story they're failing
to realize that structures away
to maximize the impact of their story
and that they are ending up presenting a
situation instead of telling a story so
the my method is a way for them to
identify the eight elements that are
required to tell a story to put them all
on a one-page form and to see how
structure can work for them not against
them in order to help them find the most
surprising and satisfying paths for
their story so it's almost as if new
screen writers or screenwriters that's
haven't mastered structure or almost
like recounting it's like it for a
deposition and they're they're sort of
recounting they look just the facts
instead of actually putting flavor and
flair and the characters voice I think
there's can be resistance to thinking
that structures gonna somehow inhibit
them you know that it's going to keep
them from finding their voice when in
fact it's quite freeing all it is it's
you know it's it's you know when people
study improv improv comedy is not just
people who run around crazy on stage
right structure is a big part of it
understanding the structures behind
different improv scenarios allows the
performers to find these interesting
paths so it allows them to free
themselves so they need just a little
bit of structure in order to discover
those moments but without them you're
gonna end up floundering so what is the
voice of the character I mean nothing
about when I listen to let's say
Margaret Atwood or Alice Munro read one
of their stories there's a very distinct
you know you feel that that person is
real it seems like such an it's such a
very vague thing like the character
voice but it's so important how does
somebody kind of like bring it down and
make it tangible well when I talk about
voice I'm not talking about the
character's voice I'm talking more about
the writers voice that the writers voice
needs to come through and that comes
through in everything all of the
elements it comes it through in your
work
choice in the way you choose to describe
action in the choice of the structure
and the story and the characters all of
the elements work together are going to
contribute to you discovering your voice
and your voice is what makes you unique
as a writer what makes it more than just
plot that there's something unique and
ultimately that's what screenwriters are
selling of themselves is that they have
an a really unique voice that captures
the imagination of the reader and makes
us experience it like a movie and not
feel like we're reading a short story us
what's the writers voice the writers boy
not yeah actor's voice not the
protagonist in Jack okay so finding the
writers voice okay that I can see where
can the writer have too much of their
own voice can it is it good to vary
their style and their voice whiter skin
dimpling get in their own way in the
beginning and that's why in the
beginning you know the real
screenwriting 101 approach is tells you
to stick to what is seen and what is
heard right then and that's that's what
we teach beginners because we want to
start training readers to writers to
rethink from what you might have learned
from writing prose which could be very
internal where we're getting inside
characters heads you don't really do
that in screenwriting at least you know
what we're generally not gonna hear the
characters thoughts literally unless use
voiceover in voiceovers in advance tool
but as you become a more experienced
writer you're gonna be you should
experiment more with breaking rules and
with not worrying about sticking to only
what is seen and heard and finding ways
to discover your voice as a writer so
that when a reader reads you it doesn't
violate the rules of screenwriting it
still is something that we can
imagine in a movie but it brings the
words to life in such a way that engages
the reader because readers are human
ultimately we want to be delighted we
want to be charmed by your writing so
ultimately I think to distinguish
yourself you're gonna want to explore
your voice and it's become more charming
as a writer in the beginning though
you're gonna get in your own way if
you're doing that too much until you've
sort of trained your brain to stop to
think more naturally about what is being
seen and heard and more naturally about
seeing everything as a movie but voice
is something that you definitely going
to need to develop along the way if you
want to distinguish yourself as a
screenwriter what about getting in your
own way in terms of copying someone
else's voice unintentionally so if I'm
devouring all these William Goldman
scripts and I'm just trying to really
sink into them and then I somehow end up
writing in his style emulating him not
knowing I'm doing that I don't know that
that's a bad thing in the beginning you
know we in any form of artistry write we
are going to copy those whose style we
admire in a way as a way to eventually
find our own voice you know if you're
literally lifting things that that would
be a problem if you are you know and
ultimately you're gonna have to develop
your own voice it definitely is I can
tell you it will be irritating to read
readers and I'll tell you a particular
writer that this was a problem with is a
little a lot of young writers copy
Tarantino for example you know in the
late 90s so we're you know because he
had such a strong voice and broke the
rules in such a way that everyone
everyone wants to break the rules and so
and that certainly can irritate a reader
when they recognize it's so clearly
somebody else's voice that it it
definitely can have a backlash effect
where we'd rather not try it any voice
at all if you're gonna just cop it where
we feel you're just copying someone else
boys but really great writers who have
very specific voices and styles I think
that can be a way to start learning how
to develop your voice to try to I don't
I don't want to say copy but to emulate
in some ways a William Goldman style if
you admire it as a way to ultimately
develop your own voice you're gonna want
to ultimately develop your own voice
because the world probably doesn't need
another William Goldman voice out there
alternately what they want is your voice
right so you it should be a step along
the way to find that so if you and I
were going to get together and I'm gonna
present to you my script and you're
gonna work out my scripts with the
nutshell techniques what are some of the
first steps and how do I do that well
they're a couple different ways I would
recommend getting my book you can get my
book on Amazon you can also most public
libraries have it okay so get my book I
recommend getting the paperback version
just because the paperback is a larger
format it's got these nice big diagrams
in the back yeah the kindle limits you
to those little teeny when these
beautiful diagrams are like an inch in
the kindle and it's difficult to flip
back and forth so to start approaching
to understand the method and then use it
to develop your story on your own if you
wanted to explore things further you
could contact me and best ways through
my website
Jill Chamberlain calm and I also on the
website you can go ahead and download
free versions of my nutshell technique
worksheets so they have them in a nice
PDF format to develop your story and
then if you wanted to contact me
I can work with writers both one-on-one
sometimes writers come to me when at the
very beginning they haven't written a
word yet but they're trying to develop
the story they want to make sure they
have a story not a situation we can set
up a consultation either in person in
Los Angeles or we can do it via Skype
where I work with the writer to make
sure that their nut shell is solid other
writers approached me after they
finished a screenplay to do a script
consultation and then I also do my
master class on the natural technique I
have a one day and I also have a two day
workshop those are in Los Angeles during
the summers those are ways that you can
work with me to understand the natural
technique more and with these master
classes do have students bring in their
own scripts and as a part of the class
you dissect with the National technique
yeah so the master closet so it's one
day and it's a two day and so we're not
gonna have time to read your screenplay
in in this but what I will do in the in
the master classes I will walk through
some movies and diagram up on the
whiteboard looking at the National
technique pointing out how it could have
ended up a situation instead of a story
looking at a couple of famous film
examples and then folks will those who
volunteer can start explaining their
story nutshells so they can bring in on
the nutshell technique form we'll talk
through it verbally and I'll work with
the writer one on one it'll be in front
of the class but as if they're not in
the room I'll work with the writer one
on one
I'd like it to do it this way because
because I created this I know this a lot
better than anyone else and so I know
the pitfalls that happen so people who
may read the book and they may really
like the idea of the method but once
they put into practice you know it's one
thing for me to show you how beautifully
it works in Groundhog Day or another
movie it's another thing to get it to
work for your own story and so they
start running into some pitfalls that
I'm familiar with so we'll go through
different volunteers examples and a
brave volunteers and we'll talk
one-on-one I'll talk one-on-one with the
writer as they talk through their
nutshell it's very similar to how I work
with writers when they work with me
one-on-one via Skype in private
consultation and then I will kind of
poke holes in their nutshell and
and the reason being is to strengthen
that to hit the pitfalls that I'm I am I
know
often happen and to help you find more
strong ways to figure out things help
help you use it to find for example that
unexpected yet interesting ending that
everyone is struggling to find there are
ways we can use the nutshell technique
to help you find that and the reason
they have some pitfalls is that because
they're so close to the work whereas if
you did Groundhogs Day and you asked
them then they have no problem that's a
big part of it right it's easy for me to
show and for everyone to understand oh I
see exactly how it works in Groundhog
Day it's quite another thing when you
apply it to your own stories and it's it
is also it's interesting because I will
be able to work with you but if you're
in the class you'll be listening to
other people presenting these stories
and I think it's really interesting for
people to try to fix the nut shells in
their heads so it's a really good
example for you as a writer particular
more experienced writer maybe you
already are think you're pretty good at
figuring out story for your self but
then you have to hear somebody else's
story and you're hearing the problems to
see if you can figure out what the
solutions will be so that's part of it
it's also just from experience that I've
just literally done thousands of these
you know and so I I very often can hear
right away where people have thought
they understood a concept of it where in
fact that they have misunderstood it a
little bit and I can just point out real
clear correctives right off the bat to
help people understand at a much deeper
level it's a very clever name the
nutshell technique what does it mean
well actually it wasn't even all that
clever I just when I first created it I
identified these eight elements I put
them on a piece of paper and I went to
label my form and I thought well just
it's basically a screenplay and
she'll and so that's what I wrote on the
forum and ended up calling it the
nutshell technique and the name has
stuck ever since so